Miranda Kerr is engaged  guys sexy when he's genuine and he's  authentic and the 33 year old model is  set to Wed 26 year old snapchat  co-founder and CEO Evan Spiegel the  Daily Mail was first to report the  engagement ET confirmed the news  Wednesday morning evans rep tells us  quote they are extremely happy and  Miranda posted this pic to Instagram  writing simply I said yes what a  sparkler a gorgeous round cut diamond  with baguettes on either side definitely  a worthwhile investment the pair has  been dating for over a year and earlier  this year  Miranda gushed to us about their  relationship that's great this will be  the first marriage for Evan and the  second for Miranda she was previously  married to actor Orlando Bloom with whom  she shares son Flynn